travis barker is on the mend after
suffering from pancreatitis
and e.t has learned his health scare has
only brought him closer to wife kourtney
kardashian
i've never met
a better human in my life a source tells
e.t court was extremely worried when the
blink 182 rocker was feeling unwell and
later rushed by ambulance to l.a cedar
sinai hospital we're told courtney has
been taking care of travis around the
clock quote she has been by travis's
side throughout everything and making
sure he is okay thankfully travis has
since been discharged paparazzi even
caught him out and about looking happy
and healthy here he is bumping fist with
a friend as he returned to the recording
studio tuesday in calabasas
no doubt that the punk rock drummer has
missed making music and we can't wait to
hear what he cooks up next yeah i can't
wait just a day before his studio sesh
travis hit the beach with courtney and
her kids penelope and rayne disick for
some rest and relaxation to cap off the
july 4th weekend
according to our e.t source quote travis
has been trying to take it easy and rest
so that he can get back to his best
healthy self soon travis and courtney
spoke out to update fans on the scary
episode both confirming that travis's
medical emergency was life-threatening
and courtney wasn't the only one worried
and we love travis we're told the entire
kardashian-jenner family was really
scared after finding out travis
diagnosis
but quote everyone is glad that travis
is on the mend now
following travis's release from the
hospital kris jenner and corey gamble
sent the rocker a get well soon bouquet
while court sisters kim khloe kylie and
kendall shipped over a beautiful
arrangement of white flowers and travis
thanked his in-laws on instagram for the
sweet gesture
as travis recovers he's been leaning on
his wife and kids for support travis is
a really amazing father it's one of the
reasons that i fell in love with him he
is very very patient i think because
we've all known each other it does make
it easier to blend our families like
it's all i could ever want
his daughters alabama and asiana thanked
their followers for the outpouring of
prayers and love for their dad
and we hope travis makes a full recovery
as he and court were on track to expand
their blended family with a baby i love
the idea of a blended family i think
that you know the more kids the merrier
and it's like more people to love i
am really close with travis's kids and i
love them and
it's a beautiful thing
[Music]